Kylie Jenner shares her pregnancy  journey and a first look at Chicago West  on Sunday the Keeping Up with the  Kardashians star announced on Instagram  that she and boyfriend Travis Scott  welcomed their baby girl to the world on  February 1st writing I just couldn't  wait to share this blessing I've never  felt love and happiness like this but a  source tells ET that the couple is still  deciding on a name adding quote Kylie  and her baby girl are doing wonderful  Kylie has always been a nurturer and  natural with babies everyone is over the  moon Kylie and Travis are enjoying their  bundle of joy the 20 year olds also  posted this video that documented her  pregnancy so I'm 34 weeks today and gave  fans a glimpse at Kim and Kanye's  newborn daughter Chicago West  [Music]  I think we're going to go to Chicago but  my eyes you